we must eat less meat and less fish we
must use genetically modified crops and
we must embrace free trade I think the
best way of feeding the world is to make
much more use of Africa Africa for
political reasons it doesn't grow a
great deal of food it could grow far
more it's the obvious place to feed the
world actually I'm not worried about
feeding nine billion people I think we
could already do that now I think the
problem is not technological and
scientific its political its
distribution of the food products that
we need to get around corrupt
governments I don't know how we can feed
nine billion people but it's all right
not to know things in science we can try
to feed nine billion people but it is
clearly beyond the carrying capacity of
yours and so we ultimately have to
reduce our importance in the world for
ultimate survival we cannot be 9 billion
people or 10 or 12 or 15 we have to be
far less well there's no magic bullet it
involves first of all coming to terms
with the fact that we will have to put a
price on the emission of carbon there's
a very simple way of reducing global co2
emissions which is to put rather high
tax on carbon it's politically difficult
but it's the obvious way of cutting
consumption at the same time there there
needs to be engagement in terms of
personal responsibility we have to make
choices that decrease our own greenhouse
footprints I'm also in favor of a
massive expansion of the nuclear program
there's been nuclear paralysis since
Chernobyl it's the obvious way of
providing clean energy and we should
boost the nuclear program worldwide I'm
not so pessimistic about co2 emissions I
think global warming is real and largely
human-caused but i think it's not clear
how disastrous it's going to be and so i
think there's time to let market forces
operate that is I'd rather encourage
people from the bottom up through
incentives tax incentives or cheaper
cars cheaper fuels alternative energy
sources I think there's time to do that
and let
that happen I'd prefer that rather than
top-down draconian by Fiat government
controls over people's freedoms of what
they can do and how they can move around
I don't think it's fair to tell
developing nations that they can't be
like us I think that's a little
hypocritical so I think there is time to
let market forces work as the great
prophet of global warming and gayer
James Lovelock says we must build more
nuclear power stations we must not turn
our back on technical fixes and at the
same time we must learn to live using
less energy and it's not a choice
between these things it's all of them
together and then we still cross our
fingers